DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don Dodge
and this is Google Root Access.
Today my guest is
Misha Leybovich.
He's president and
CEO of Meograph.
Welcome.
MISHA LEYBOVICH: Thanks!
Good to be here.
DON DODGE: So tell
me about Meograph.
What is it?
What does it do?
MISHA LEYBOVICH: So we're a
multimedia creation platform.
Makes it easy to combine video,
audio, images, text, links,
music, other interactive.
Very simple interface
and compelling output
that's kind of like multimedia
stories, mixes, and mashups.
And that's what we've had live
on our site for about a year.
Where people come,
they create content,
then they share it
via social networks
or embed it other places.
What we're moving
towards now, and what
we're going to
talk about here, is
we're now licensing that
creation platform itself
to other companies so they
can embed it in their site
as a native branded experience
with all the enterprise
features around it.
And engage their customers and
creating user generated content
about their brands, their
products, and their services.
DON DODGE: So let's
talk business models.
You started with
the a B to C model.
Tell us about that.
How did that work?
MISHA LEYBOVICH:
Well at first, I
was just trying to
solve my own problem.
That I had done a lot of
traveling after college.
I had been to about 70
countries in the seven years
after college.
And had a lot of cool
media, love telling stories,
but I have no multimedia
creation skills.
Don't know how to use
Final Cut Pro or Photoshop
or Premiere or anything.
So I just want a way to
create richer content
myself to tell cool
stories online.
In a way that I felt it
was native to the way
with all these different media.
So we put it out there
just because, hey,
if I like doing it, other
people might like doing it too,
and let's see what happens.
So it has been great.
We've grown very fast.
We have tens of thousands
of regular users.
Yesterday, we had over
half a million page views.
So we're doing well.
But as we really started
to think about it,
like where does the business
actually exists there?
We started to realize, gosh,
it's difficult to actually
build a business
off of storytelling,
a consumer
ad-supported business.
Because for that, you
need tens or hundreds
of millions users that use
you weekly, if not daily.
And storytelling
is something that
is valuable and important
but not frequent.
Maybe a couple times of year.
So that sort of model
wasn't going to work for us.
So we start to think
about more B to B. Offer
this for other businesses
to create content themselves
about their brands.
And there we found
that our product,
while interesting and
different, the end result of it
was not differentiated enough
from them just going and hiring
a video crew to do something
custom, exactly as they need.
Hard to build a
business that way.
But as we started talking
to these businesses
and we're talking
the marketers, we
said look, you want
your customers,
your audience, to
create content.
You want them to be engaged, you
would buzz around your brand.
Why don't you get them to
use our product, it's totally
consumer grade and super
easy, to create content
about your business.
And the feedback we kept getting
was we like your product and we
like our customers
taking this action,
but how is it going to work?
We're going to send
them to your site,
and they're going to create
an account on Meograph,
create content.
Spend all the time, by the
way, and all the engagement
on your site rather than
ours, grab the embed code,
if they know what that is,
come back and paste it.
Ta da!
It's a lot of steps.
And so we started
thinking about well
if we could provide
this on your site
as a branded native experience,
is that interesting?
And there we started to really
get very positive feedback
from companies.
DON DODGE: So the product
solves a complexity problem
and makes it easier for mere
mortals to create nice content.
So you found a problem
and you solved it,
but in applying a
revenue model to it,
consumers weren't
willing to pay,
businesses had alternatives
it wasn't that differentiated.
So B2C didn't work,
B2B didn't work,
and now you're doing B2B2c
where the business' media
companies are your
customers, and they're
the ones that are
pay, and the consumers
are using it and
creating content.
MISHA LEYBOVICH: Right.
That's exactly it.
It's very difficult.
It's difficult to get a
consumer's time and creativity
in the first place.
To get their money as well,
is nye impossible to the scale
of building a
really big business.
DON DODGE: So let's
talk about the pivots.
So you pivoted now three times.
Typically when you
pivot, you think,
well if I only
added more features,
or if I could make
it easier to use,
or if I tried different
marketing it would work.
So making those
pivot decisions, how
did you get through that to
decide, no I've got to change?
MISHA LEYBOVICH: You just got
to be honest with yourself
about what your product is, what
it's good at and what it's not,
and ultimately what
real business value
you're providing to someone.
Because someone is going
to write you a check.
If it's a
consumer-based business,
its advertisers writing a check.
But someone is
writing you a check.
We just had to really think
about what does our product do
and what real problem
does it solve for someone
that can write a check.
This sounds like a silly thing,
like it should be obvious.
But before this, I was
at McKinsey & Company,
a big business consulting
firm for two years.
Did a lot of business problems,
and you would think that that
would be self apparent, but
I think a lot of the culture
around early-stage
entrepreneurship right now is,
like Paul Graham says, "Build
something people want. "
And that's important.
That's a baseline.
That's table stakes.
But it's not sufficient.
You have to build
something that people want
and that someone will pay for.
Someone will write a
check at some point.
And so we just had to
be honest with ourselves
as we went along this journey as
to what value are we providing
for someone, how can we
help them get promoted
or not get fired, whoever it
is that's writing the check,
and how do we give
them the things
that they need where they can
prove the value around it?
DON DODGE: Awesome!
So where these true pivots where
you stopped doing something
and started doing
it a different way,
or today do you still have a B2C
direct-to-consumer component,
a direct-to-business component,
and now this new model?
MISHA LEYBOVICH: It's
really been an evolution.
If you come to our site, you
can still create content there
and then embed it elsewhere.
And that's great for us,
it's a great publicity.
People buzz about the product.
And we learn.
We learn from hearing
user feedback about it.
Businesses still use it.
Major news orgs still just
use us, embed us in their page
to tell multimedia stories
and businesses do too.
And so now our new build
is all these enterprise
features around to
the creation product.
So when you embed
it in your site now,
you have the moderation, the
analytics, the customization,
the ability to embed it
with one line of code
so it's not complex to do.
It's all on top of
the core product.
And it all still stays true
to the original mission
of just wanting to make
it easy for mere mortals
to create rich content and
express themselves and tell
stories about things
that they care about.
And now we're allowing
people to do that
but really providing
value to the people who
are willing to pay and benefit
when that thing happens.
DON DODGE: So you solved
the customer problem
or the complexity
problem fairly early on,
but the real journey
was figuring out
what is the revenue
model and business
model that can make this
into this a business.
MISHA LEYBOVICH: Sure.
And to be honest,
sometimes you just
got to wonder in the
desert for a little bit
until you figure it out.
I don't think that we would have
stumbled across this problem
that marketers have.
They're thinking about the
rise of content marketing,
they're thinking about
more user engagement
and two-way relationships
with their customer base.
I didn't know all
that when we started.
Nor would we have had a
consumer grade end-product
that was good enough for them.
So it's OK to wander
for a little bit
and figure it out, but at some
point not too long after that,
you have to think about
what really, really
what does the
business come down to?
DON DODGE: So the lesson
then for founders and viewers
is keep trying different revenue
models and business models.
Sometimes you have the
technical problems solved,
it's how do you
make it a business.
MISHA LEYBOVICH: Right.
And if you don't have
it figured out to start,
don't use it as an excuse
to not get started.
Get going, try something,
put it out there,
and get some validation
that at least you've
built something
that people want.
But don't have your
business strategy
rely on a hope and a prayer that
you catch lightning in a bottle
and that it becomes an overnight
part of the cultural Zeitgeist.
If it is, then great.
But it's good to
really think about
where can you provide business
value around whatever it
is you're building.
DON DODGE: Great advice.
Well thank you, Misha.
Thank you for joining us.
MISHA LEYBOVICH: Thank you.
DON DODGE: I'd like to
remind our viewers that we
have a $2000 credit
for Google Cloud.
So if you're developing
applications in the cloud,
try out the Google Cloud and
get a $2000 credit for doing it.
The way to sign up for it
will be right on your screen.
Thank you for joining us
and see you next time.